Kim Kardashian proves she's a natural in  the co-host seat the 36 year old reality  star filled in for Kelly Ripa on Mondays  live with Kelly and Ryan but she didn't  miss a beat chatting about everything  from her kids north in st. she does not  like her brother she thinks she's  outsmarting me she's like we're having a  tea party mom no boys allowed then  she'll just slam the door on her  brother's face to her bedtime rituals  with hubby Kanye West do you and Kanye  ever sleep in separate beds not in  tension not intentionally I thought used  to like intentional Plus you got real  about all those tabloid rumors do you  believe about yourself online about him  even proved she's got interviewing  skills sitting down with Eric Dean and  Kellie Pickler but no mention of frenemy  Taylor Swift who debuted her new music  video at Sunday's VMAs  that's because mondays live was actually  pre-taped  [Music]